Morrill: All righty.
Wow, this is a-a more packed
room than I expected
considering
the little bit of news
at the end
of the keynote there.
I expected that all you guys
would be downstairs right now.
But thanks for coming, anyway.
Um...
So my name is Dan Morrill.
I'm with
Google Developer Relations.
And I'm here today to, you know,
give you this presentation
on "How Do I Code Thee?
Let Me Count the Ways."
And really the point here
is to illustrate
to you guys,
um, the various ways
that you can build applications
on Android.
So, you know, let's get started
and get right into it.
So the first question I want
to answer is, "What is Android?"
Um, well, you know,
at the bottom of Android,
we have the Linux Kernel.
And this is essentially
what we use
for our
hardware abstraction layer.
And this is where all the device
drivers live and so on.
Um, above that we have
the native libraries
for things like media...
You know what?
This isn't
what I want to do today
'cause I think we've used
this slide
at every single presentation
that we've ever done.
I think it's time to put
this thing
out to pasture and move on.
So let me start over again.
[cheers and applause]
What is Android?
Well, I want to make today
the case
that Android
is really three things.
The first is a chunk
of code for making phone calls.
I owned one of those things.
It was an awesome phone
back in the day.
Um, and when I say it's a chunk
of code for making phone calls,
what I really mean is,
you know, originally,
cell phones had only
enough software to read input
and drive the radio stack
to place a phone call--
you know, single-function
devices and so on.
And of course, you know,
obviously Android,
as a, you know,
mobile-phone stack, has exactly
that capability as well.
So it's a chunk of code
for making calls.
Android is also, you know,
a robust network stack
and Internet client.
And I remember, oh,
I don't even know, like,
five or more years ago,
there was this TV commercial
for one of the big carriers.
Um, and it had a woman
who had a brand-new cell phone,
and she was very proud of it.
And she was bragging
about her new phone
to, you know, a friend
or something like that.
And the conversation went on
for a moment
until somebody asked a question
that she couldn't answer,
and the friend says, "Oh, well,
I'll just get my phone out
and search the Internet
for it."
And I remember this commercial,
because the woman said
in this dejected, like,
most plaintive voice
you can imagine, "You can get
the Internet on your phone?"
And it was--
I just laughed out loud
when I saw it,
not because it was funny,
but because, to me, it's like,
that's something
that I was already expecting
even five years ago.
And so, you know, today,
you know, Android has
a robust network stack
and Internet client.
We've got a state-of-the-art
Web browser,
you know, and a full TCIP--
TCP/IP stack.
And, of course, the third thing,
and really the thing
that I want to talk about most
today is Android is a platform
for running code.
Let me talk about that
a bit more.
What do I mean
by running code?
Well, Android has
an application model of its own.
You guys are probably familiar
or have heard
of the Dalvik virtual machine.
And, you know, made available
to Dalvik
is a variety of core framework
APIs and so on.
Um, but, you know,
I love reading the press,
because people, even today,
will still print things
like, "Oh, you know, Google's
looking to extend its dominance
to cell phones."
That really isn't
what Android is about.
We created Android
to be the open mobile platform
that we needed.
You know,
and so from that perspective,
we don't really necessarily
"care," per se,
how you guys build
your applications.
We built the APIs
that run in Dalvik
to be an intentionally
loosely coupled--
and I like to describe them
as a federation of components.
But basically what that means
is that your application
consists of components
you write,
as well as components
that you pull in
from other applications that
are installed on the device.
Um, and so those components
can include the Web.
And they can, you know, also
include aspects of native code
if you want to write code
that way as well.
In other words, you know,
basically we just love code.
Android is about letting
developers get their apps
into users' hands
on a mobile device
however, you know,
it works best for you.
And so, you know,
in other words, you know,
we welcome all code
from, you know, from anywhere.
Yeah, I made this SPG myself.
You can probably tell.
Um, but, yeah, you know, really
we want to liberate your code
and give you guys the openness
and freedom
that you need
to build applications.
So all that said,
that's the tone
of what I want
to talk about today.
So this is my agenda.
You know, what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna demonstrate
to you guys
three ways of writing code,
kind of the three key ways
of writing code for Android.
I'm gonna demonstrate
how to use them,
so I'm gonna actually, you know,
show you some code and so on.
And then towards the end,
I'm also gonna draw
some conclusions,
give you some useful comparisons
and statistics
that you guys can use when
you're making your own decisions
about application architecture.
Throughout, I'm also going to,
you know, give you guys
a taste of the road map
and some of the features
that are coming.
I do want to take
another moment
to explain
what I'm not gonna cover.
I'm gonna assume
that everybody here
either already knows
how to build, you know,
a Dalvik application for Android
or knows how to build
an Ajax application,
so I'm not gonna spend
a lot of time talking about
the basics of app development.
There's documentation online.
There's, you know, other
sessions that you can go to
today and tomorrow
to cover all that.
Um, the other thing I'm not
gonna do is pass judgment.
I'm not gonna give you
a pat answer.
I'm not gonna give you,
you know, kind of a, you know,
magic solution or an equation
that you solve for
that tells you the right way
to build your application.
My real aim here is to arm
you guys with the knowledge
that you need to make
your own informed decisions
about app development.
So, you know, without further
ado, let's get into it.
So what are the three flavors
of Android development?
Well, first is native code,
which runs on,
as I've alluded to before,
a Dalvik virtual machine.
This is a virtual machine
on the same order
of, you know, a Java virtual
machine or a .Net CLR.
It's a virtual machine
that runs some byte code.
The second way is Ajax,
who I believe is the guy
on the left.
And Ajax is essentially
a technique for making
dynamic user interfaces
in a Web browser,
typically also talking
to the network
and communicating to the server
for data operations.
And then the third kind
is native code,
which in the current builds
of Android include support
for the ARM processor
written in C code.
So let me then--
[clears throat] excuse me--
jump into a bit more detail
about Dalvik.
Um, but wait.
I actually need an example.
Um, so what I want to do today
is--I've just described
three different ways
of writing code.
What I'm actually going to do
is write the same app
all three ways,
essentially the same app
using all three techniques.
And so to do this
I need kind of a sample,
or guinea pig, algorithm
to show you guys how this works
and have
an apples-to-apples comparison.
It needs to be externally--
or efficiently externalizable.
And it has to make for
an interesting demonstration.
I'm not just gonna show
you guys, um,
you know, some things
without pretty pictures as well.
So this is just a text
of what I'm going to describe
on the next slide.
So what I'm gonna do today,
and this is a shout-out
to my friend and colleague
Kelly Norton,
who, when I kind of whined
about needing an algorithm,
the first words out of his mouth
were "K-Means clustering."
So I looked it up, and I'm like,
"Ah, yes, that's perfect."
Um, but what it is
is essentially it's a member
of an algorithm family
that Google actually uses
a lot internally
for, you know,
"machine learning" style things,
where we're, you know, doing
some text processing and so on.
So it's apropos to Google.
And the way it works is--
you see up there
there's a number of gray squares
and then some colored red dots.
The gray squares
are data points.
And they're essentially
distributed, you know,
however your data
is distributed.
The way K-Means works
is basically you have
one mean point,
which is the circles,
associated with every cluster
that you want to create.
So in the example depicted here,
which came from Wikipedia,
they're actually three groups--
red, green, and blue--
and they're clustering
those 12 gray points
into the three groups.
So the algorithm's
actually very simple.
All you do is compute which mean
every point is closest to
and associate it
with that cluster.
Then after you've done
all of that,
you iterate
over the groups again,
and you recompute the centroid
or, you know,
the mean or the average
or the center point of each
cluster based on all the new--
as the average of all
the new members in the group.
And this is a greedy algorithm.
You keep running it
until it converges
or until you decide to stop.
So that's the algorithm
that I'm going to implement.
[clears throat]
Um, and, you know, as you
can see here on the right,
I don't think--yeah, there's
kind of a big black area
in the upper left corner.
That's actually
a dark-blue color,
so sorry for the low visibility
on that.
But as you can see,
it's essentially just plots
each of the points according
to which group it is in
by color-coded scheme.
Okay, so now back to Dalvik.
So Dalvik is...
a virtual machine
as I mentioned earlier.
And so it's similar
to the .Net CLR
or a Java virtual machine.
It's memory-protected,
garbage-collected,
and life cycle-managed
and so on.
It's optimized
for embedded machines, though,
meaning that, you know,
one of the reasons
why we didn't just adopt,
you know,
say, a Java virtual machine
for Android
is because the stack model that
a Java virtual machine defines
introduces a lot of overhead
when you're running
on a, you know,
a register-based processor
and so on.
And so for that reason we have
a custom byte code format,
and the tool chain includes
a converter that translates
to Dalvik byte code
from Java byte code.
Um, so how do you write an app
on Dalvik?
Well, generally you just write
Java source code.
It goes through that compilation
and translation phase.
And, you know, you make use
of the framework APIs
that are provided
by the system,
and that's things
like the view hierarchy
and, you know,
network access and so on.
Um, the APIs that need to be
are backed by native code,
meaning that, you know, like,
OpenGL, interprocess
communication, and so on,
these all punch down
into native code out of Dalvik
to do the actual work.
And so, you know, we do support
the popular development tools.
That's one of the reasons
why we went out of our way
to include support
for the Java language,
and we have
an Eclipse plug-in available,
which, you know,
we have a screenshot
of that running there.
Um, so what can you do
with Dalvik?
Well, the key thing with Dalvik
is that you can do rich clients
with it.
It's the richest form
of app development on Android.
Um, you can do--you have full
control of the user interface.
You can run code
in the background.
You can share components
either from applications
that you use yourself,
or you can export components
that other applications can use.
You have the option
to do tight integration
with system events in UI.
But again, I'm not gonna cover
all this in detail,
'cause there's other sessions
you can go to
and you can check
our online docs.
So, you know, the other thing
I want to cover is, well,
what can you not do, what are
the limitations of Dalvik?
And, you know,
clearly not much.
You know, we've built Android
so that Dalvik is the primary,
you know, execution environment.
It's the crossroads,
if you will,
of all the other components
that--that I'll describe later.
And that's really quite literal.
It is a crossroads.
I don't expect you to understand
what that means, though,
but by the end of the session,
after I've gone
through all the demos,
I think you guys
will understand what I mean
when I say crossroads.
Of course,
that doesn't necessarily mean
that it's the right thing
for every application out there.
If you're writing an application
that's performance-intensive
and you need a lot of speed,
um, you know,
sometimes it may make sense--
and I'll just foreshadow here--
to use native code for that.
In other cases, if you're
just building sort of an adjunct
to a Web site and you just want
a mobile presence,
you know, you may not need
things like tight integration
and background processing,
and in that case it may make
sense to go ahead and use
an Ajax app for that.
So let me stop, you know,
talking and just showing slides
for just a moment
and jump out to Eclipse
and do a quick demo for you.
So here I have Eclipse
with the Android plug-in ADT
installed.
And the first thing
I'm going to do
is import an existing project...
um, from my demo directory.
And so this is some code
that I wrote.
[clears throat]
And I have a quick error
that I have to correct.
Oh, okay, good,
I recompiled it away.
Um, so, yeah,
this is my project.
Now, um, the first thing
that I want to start with
is, you know, this one class
here called KMeansActivity.
As you can see,
this is very simple.
All this is essentially doing,
if you're not super-familiar
with Android development--
all this is really doing
is it's describing the creation
of a single screen, you know,
that takes up
my phone's display.
And it essentially defines that
this layout that I've defined
in an XML file is what
I should display in that screen.
So if you look at that XML file,
which I'll open over here--
um, you could just go
to the XML view--
you can see that the entire view
itself was also very simple
and consists of this K-Means
view class that I wrote.
Okay, so let's look
at that view class.
Um, this class has down here
a bunch of boilerplate
for handling--
[clears throat] excuse me--
surface changes,
so, like, the screen resizes,
or the device reorients
or something like that.
Um, but really
the magic happens up here.
And what I'm doing
is I'm creating this class
called KMeansThread.
Now, if you want more detail on
what exactly is going on here,
this is based
on the Lunar Lander demo
in the STK sample code,
so you can check that out
for a more kind of robust
example of how animation works.
But it's adapted from that,
and really all I'm doing
is I'm passing it
a new thread, two arguments.
One is this older object,
which is a handle to a canvas
so that the thread can do
its own drawing
directly into that surface,
but the other thing
is this class here
called the Dalvik clusterer.
So let's look at that.
Dalvik clusterer
is an implementation
of this Clusterer interface.
So let's go there real quick.
And all Clusterer does
is define a point,
and this is just a carrier class
or, you know,
the NxNy coordinate pair and
a designation of which cluster
that point
is currently associated with.
So in other words, this is
kind of the raw data point
that my algorithm operates over.
And then it defines
this other method down here
called Clusterer, which takes
a list of points and performs
that K-Means clustering
that I described earlier.
So if I go back to Dalvik,
then, you see that I over--
I implement the Cluster method.
I have this other method down
here, which is just computing
the cartesian distance between
two points in a 2D plane.
But really the magic happens
in this loop up here.
So I initialize a bunch
of variables
to, you know,
some insane value,
but the loop I want to focus on
is this one here.
You can see that this loop runs
until I decide
that the algorithm
has converged,
and, you know, this block here
is really where the heart
of the algorithm happens,
and, as you can see,
it's pretty simple.
For every point in my list,
for every group,
or, you know, every cluster
that I'm processing,
compute the distance
between the current point
and the current center
of the group,
and then see if that distance
is less than the distance
from the current point
to the group
it's currently associated with.
So in other words, I'm just
looking for the low watermark
of the centroid, or mean,
of each group
that the current point
is closest to.
In other words, if the point
is determined to be closer
to the current group than
the group it's currently in,
I update the information here
to say that,
"Okay, you're now in the new
group that you're closest to."
Um, after that, I just have--
you know, if it converged,
if there was no data change,
then that means
that the algorithm is over,
and I can do an early break.
And then in here, I just have
a block where I recompute
the centroids as that last step
before the next iteration.
So that's it.
This is a pretty
straightforward,
you know, algorithm.
So let me run this for you.
So I'll create a new launcher
called "KMeans."
And run this...
on my device...
which I have here.
And you can see
in the background,
Eclipse is launching activity.
And then there it is running.
Okay, the autofocuser's having
a little bit of trouble there,
but you can see
that what it's doing is--
up here, there's two numbers
that are being drawn.
The top number is the
rendering time in milliseconds,
and the bottom number
is the computation time
in milliseconds.
And the point
that I want to make
is that it renders actually
really fast,
on the order
of 15 to 18 milliseconds.
And that's the time it takes
to physically draw
500 color-coded points
on the screen.
But the computation time here
is quite clearly the bottleneck,
on the order of almost a second
in some cases.
So that's it.
That's the basic algorithm.
This is the most boring
implementation of this
that you're gonna see today.
Um, consider it the baseline.
So--So what are some examples
of Dalvik apps
in the real world?
Um, well, the core system apps
are all Dalvik applications.
Here you see the dialer.
And additionally, nearly all
of the apps currently available
on the market,
such as Google Sky Map,
which you see on the right here,
are also, you know, Android--
or, excuse me, are also
Dalvik applications.
So what are some of the things
that we're gonna be working on
in the future for Dalvik apps?
Uh, well,
improved garbage collection,
as well as, the team
has also started work
on the Just-In-Time compiler
and, you know, as always,
additional optimizations
in the core libraries,
so, you know,
some of the libraries
that are available to you
will get faster over time.
And then, of course, you know,
we're not gonna sit idle.
Dalvik is the main place.
It is the main embodiment of all
of the device framework APIs.
And so things like Bluetooth,
you know, peer-to-peer
networking, and so on,
these will start to appear
in--in Dalvik APIs.
So the next thing I want to do
is talk about Web apps
or Ajax apps for a moment.
So Ajax applications
are characterized,
or at least I like to think
of them as being characterized,
as really a separation
of your UI and your appearance
in the form of, you know,
HTML and CSS and so on.
Your declarative layout
as separate from the code
that runs and mutates
your layout.
And so the general model here
is that, you know,
in an Ajax application
you have the browser running,
you've specified
a document tree and
the appearance in HTML and CSS,
and you're running
some JavaScript code
in the browser to, you know,
mutate or change.
You add data, you remove data,
you animate things, and so on.
You can do limited
network access at least
in the old-school way
of doing Ajax
via, you know, this notion
of XMLHttpRequest,
which lets you issue requests
back to your server
to store data, read data,
perform other operations,
and so on.
And then recently, there's
this thing that, you know,
obviously you guys saw
quite a bit of
in the keynote this morning
about, you know, this canvas tag
that is relatively new.
And this allows JavaScript
to do something
that it couldn't do before,
which is direct painting.
Now, in the keynote, you might
recall that Vic mentioned--
you know,
he asked the question,
"How do you draw
a diagonal line?"
Similarly, in the old-school way
of doing JavaScript,
if you're at all familiar
with that programming model,
you probably realize it would
also be pretty difficult
to do something as simple
as draw 500 color-coded points
on the screen.
Fortunately, we have
the canvas tag,
and that gives us
a lot more flexibility and power
in JavaScript applications
than we had before.
So what about Ajax specifically
on Android?
Um, so these are notes
on Android 1.5,
which is the current version
that is being distributed
to users worldwide.
Um, the browser in Android
is based on WebKit,
and currently it's based
on the SquirrelFish JavaScript
virtual machine.
Um, the specific version
of WebKit
is equivalent to Safari 4 beta.
But oops, due to a bug
in the browser code of 1.5,
it's actually still reporting
as Safari 3.1.2.
So you've got all of
the Safari 4 beta functionality
and speed and so on.
We're just misreporting
the user-agent string.
It does include Gears 0.5.17.0,
which is one
of the more recent Gears builds,
including Geolocation support.
Um, and then of course,
it does include support
for that canvas tag
that I mentioned earlier
and, in fact, has included that
even since version 1.0.
Well, what can you do with this?
Well, you know it's
a state-of-the-art browser,
and so it's really good
at rendering static pages
if that's really what
you want to do.
But we're here
to talk about applications,
which are quite a bit more
dynamic than just static pages.
And so, you know, you can do
anything that you can do
in, you know, a desktop browser
on Android.
You can fetch data,
and then, of course, the big
issue is, you know, HTML5.
I hope you guys are excited
by some of the stuff
you saw in the keynote.
All that is coming to Dalv--
or, excuse me,
it's coming to Android
over time in the browser.
Um, right now we've got Gears.
That's what
you can start coding to today.
And over time,
we'll shift over to HTML5.
Um, but, yeah, I mean,
HTML5 lets you do everything
that you'd like
to be able to do.
You can access your location.
You can run code out of band
in the background,
store pages in data locally
and everything.
So I mentioned this earlier.
Android does not
currently have HTML5.
It has elements of it.
Over time, we're gonna be adding
more elements.
And in the meantime,
you can use Gears.
But the big things
that you can't do,
even with this model,
on Android,
are things
like background processing.
And what I mean there is if the
browser's not running at all,
you know, any application
that would normally run
in your browser page context
is not executing.
And so that does limit
what you can do to some extent,
you know,
with an Ajax application.
The only thing that you can't do
is you can't access the system
in framework APIs.
You know, so things like,
you know, GL,
you know,
some of the networking APIs,
the ability to open
arbitrary TCP/IP sockets.
You can't do these things
through a strict
Ajax application...
by default.
So hold that thought.
I'll come back to that later.
So what I want to do now
is show you a quick demo
of the same algorithm
that I showed you earlier,
but this time implemented
as, you know,
in a browser application.
So this is--this browser
that I'm running here
with--I believe that's Cut Man
up there--
is Safari 4, one of the betas.
So what I want to do is
go to this URL.
This is a plain, old--
you can enter that URL
in your own browser
if you want.
It's just a plain, old app
engine instance that I'm using
as a convenient way
to store some files.
So this is...
let me just rerun this
a few times,
and you can see that, you know,
this is also doing
the same thing here--
the same algorithm,
you know, yellow here,
green here,
purple, blue, orange, red.
It's the exact same behavior
as you just saw running
on the device over here
but done in a desktop browser.
Um, the first thing I want to do
is point out these speeds.
Again, those same numbers
are the same ones
that you just saw here.
Nine milliseconds drawing time
and six milliseconds
computation time.
This is
a state-of-the-art browser.
You know, on a desktop,
running at--
I don't even know
how fast these things are,
these MacBooks.
Another thing I want to do,
though, is run this--
you know, I also have installed
on my Mac here
an early build of Chromium.
And you can see here that this
is also screamingly fast.
So these are, you know,
state-of-the-art
desktop browsers,
and that's the first point
I want to draw--
or the first distinction
that I want to make.
Let me just point this out
to you guys.
You know, phones--
it doesn't matter
what kind of a phone it is
or what operating system
it's running.
Phones are slow.
And that isn't gonna change
for a long time.
You know, they're fast enough
so that the user interface
can feel smooth and fluid
and so on.
But when it comes
right down to it,
a lot of what you do
is just not ever gonna be
as fast, for a long time,
on one of these things
as it is on one of these things.
And I'm not trying to say that
to dissuade you
or anything like that.
All I'm doing is just trying
to make sure
that everybody understands
that, you know,
these are much, you know,
more limited hardware
than a desktop
and not to fall
into the trap of thinking
that, you know,
one size fits all.
You've got to understand
your application.
If speed is important
to your app,
this is something that you
should maybe think about.
Um, at any rate,
what I want to do now
is show you the source code
for this thing.
Um, so this
is the actual HTML page.
As you can see,
it's super, super simple.
Um, I have a canvas element
with an ID of "kmeans."
I have a div, which is
this thing at the bottom
where I draw--
or where I display
the execution times.
And then here I just call
the single JavaScript function
called Draw.
And it's defined in this
external file that I include
called "kmeans.js."
So this is just
a straight-up JavaScript code.
You can see that I, you know,
allocate some variables
and constants up here.
I have, again,
an implementation
as a separate function of that
cartesian distance function.
And here's, again, the--
you know, the cluster algorithm
where the heart
of the code goes on.
Again, a block up front
of just initializing variables.
And here again
is that main loop.
This should look
a little familiar.
This is literally a direct
transcription of the same code
from Java into JavaScript.
And you can see here,
you know, for every point,
for every group,
compute the distance
between the current point
and the current group,
and if that distance
is less than the distance
to the, you know,
point's current group,
update the information and say
you now belong to the new group.
I have the same early,
you know, loop break.
I have the same centroid
calculation, you know,
as the last step
in the iteration.
And again, I have the same early
break-out after 15 iterations.
Um, this reset function--
one thing I didn't mention
about the Dalvik version
is that, when you run this,
it's actually starting
by eliminating
or basically regenerating
all of the input points
to be a completely random set
of input.
And so that's what
this reset function does.
There's an equivalent method
in the Dalvik version
you saw earlier
called Prepare.
And then the final thing
is this Draw algorithm.
Now, what I want to do
is actually--
if I can do this--
show these side by side,
because I think this
is really cool.
Where's the thread?
You don't have the thread open.
So the...
Okay, here's the Draw method
in the Dalvik version.
Okay, so, you know, again,
we do some initialization.
We call the cluster algorithm.
But this is really,
down here, the loop
where the actual work gets done
in terms of drawing.
And you can see here
that in the JavaScript version,
using Canvas,
we get a handle to a context
that we can actually draw on.
Um, and then we come down
to the loop,
and we just say, okay, well,
your current fill style,
which is really
the drawing properties,
is a black--pure black color.
And all I do
is I just draw a rectangle
encompassing the entire canvas,
and that creates
the black background.
And then on top of that,
I draw each point in turn,
color-coded via the cluster
that it currently belongs in.
And that is, astonishingly,
at least to me,
similar to the Dalvik version,
where instead of--
where the JavaScript version
actually has you set
those drawing properties
on the canvas object itself,
in Dalvik there's actually just
a separate container class
for that that encapsulates
all the drawing properties
called Paint.
But other than that,
it's strikingly similar.
I do a Draw ARGB, which
basically blanks the screen,
and then I draw a point
in this case--
in JavaScript Canvas all you can
draw is a rectangle with,
you know, dimensions of 1x1.
Um, but in Dalvik, you can
actually just draw a point.
But, you know, again,
it's the same thing.
I just pick each point
by the color
of the cluster it's in.
So these are very,
very similar drawing schemes
or paradigms.
So what I want to do now, then,
is switch back to the device
and run this.
So I'm launching the browser.
And hopefully it picked it up
from my browser history
correctly.
Oh, I'm on edge.
Okay, so there it was.
I just loaded
the pure JavaScript version.
And there again, you know,
it's very similar
to the display that you just saw
on the desktop.
But what I want to call
your attention to down here
is these rendering times.
334 milliseconds for drawing
and 698 milliseconds
for the clustering computation.
So, you know, on the whole,
it's a little bit--
it's pretty comparable
in performance to Dalvik,
although perhaps
a little bit slower.
But that rendering time is--
or at least it can be
for many applications--
that rendering time
can be quite problematic.
Um, and again, just compare that
to the desktop.
You know, it's the exact same
JavaScript code,
but it's running something
on the order
of 10 or 20 times faster
on the desktop
than it is
on one of these things.
Again, I'm not trying
to dissuade you.
Just be aware of that
as you design your applications.
Okay, so that was an Ajax demo.
What are some examples
of this?
Well, you know, you saw some
earlier today.
The Google Reader, which is one
of my favorite Web applications,
you know, the Google Mail Client
that you guys have seen.
There's obviously a number
of different Web applications
that have been developed for
a certain fruit-flavored phone
out there.
So what's gonna come
in the future?
Well, HTML5 is not
gonna sit still.
You guys saw the future
of Web technologies in general,
and hopefully many
of these things
will start to become
standardized
and get rolled into HTML5.
Specifically for Android,
Gears today, HTML5 tomorrow.
The team is already working--
the browser team's working
on upgrading to a faster
JavaScript virtual machine.
You guys may be aware
there's kind of three out there.
There's TraceMonkey by Firefox,
SquirrelFish Extreme
that Safari's using in V8,
which is what Google's using
in Chrome,
you know, and they're looking
at whether we can pull
any of these three
into the browser
and increase JavaScript
performance even more.
You know, and then,
as for the other things you saw,
like O3D, the 3D technology
that currently operates
as a browser plug-in,
things like that, you know,
who knows?
It's likely that they'll
probably, you know, trail
the mobile space, 'cause first
they need to get standardized
and then mobile platforms
need to implement them.
But, you know, the future
is bright.
And it's pretty exciting,
at least to me.
Now, I want to take
one last one.
I asked you earlier
to hold a thought,
and that thought was,
you know, if you've got
an Ajax application,
you can't necessarily
get access
to a lot
of the core framework APIs.
Well, there's--
one thing that you can do--
here I'm showing
a Dalvik virtual machine.
This would be a standard,
you know, Android application.
Contained in that are a bunch
of Java objects
that are communicating
with each other and so on.
Also in this virtual machine,
as part of the view tree,
is this notion that we have
of a WebView.
Now, a WebView is literally just
a WebKit component
wrapped up in the semantics
of an Android view,
and it allows you
to pull HTML rendering
embedded into your application
UI along with other widgets.
But we also have this other
interesting little method
that we've added called
addJavaScriptInterface.
I'm gonna talk
about this a bit more later,
but really what this does
is it lets you turn
a standard Ajax application
into, like,
a super Ajax application,
or what I like
to call augmented Ajax.
And what it really does is
it lets you inject functionality
into your JavaScript code.
I'm gonna demo this,
but I'm gonna demo this
a little bit later.
So I'm gonna ask you again
to hold that thought
and come back to it.
Um, so the third kind of key way
of developing applications
for Android is this notion
of native code.
What is this for?
Well, it generally--
you know, native code
is for doing heavy lifting.
Um, this is a component
that you can kind of pull
into an existing--or pull
into a Dalvik application,
but really,
the Dalvik virtual machine
is the one running the show.
It's the app--it's the code
that gets started
and starts running,
loads up, you know,
the appropriate chunk
of native code, and then starts
making calls into it
via the Java Native Interface.
To do this you need
a Native toolchain, including...
you know, like
a GCC Cross-Compiler and so on
so that you can actually compile
C or C++ code
into a, you know,
an ARM ELF shared library
that you can run on the device.
So a work-in-progress, what
we call Native Development Kit,
or NDK, which is a companion
and/or complement
to the standard STK that you
guys are already familiar with.
We recently added one
to the donut branch
in the public Git repository.
Um, so what I'm gonna do
a little later
is gonna demo an early kind of
interim build for that thing,
and I'll talk more
about that later.
So what is this thing for?
Well, it's really for physics
and mathematical simulations.
Um, this K-Means clustering
algorithm
that I'm showing you guys
is a great example.
It's also for, you know, fast
loading of large-ish data files.
So, you know, if you've got,
like, a really massive, say,
XML document or some binary file
or something like that,
and, you know, parsing it
in Java is too memory-intensive
or too slow, you can write
C code instead
and do the heavy lifting
that way.
Another common use of this
is for input-management engines,
i.e., onscreen keyboards,
and, you know,
these are for things
like text prediction and so on.
You know, user's sitting there,
typing away furiously
on this thing.
If you really, really, really
need a fast look-up,
you know, this is a case
where you might use that.
Other things
are custom virtual machines,
you know, for things
like obsolete games and so on.
Um, there's also, of course,
other things you can do there.
You know, you can run--it's
just native code it's running.
It can see in the process,
you know, address space
all kinds of other libraries.
The issue with using them isn't
so much whether you can use them
but whether you should use them.
And this is the same story
that we tell
even when you're writing
Dalvik code.
We have public APIs,
or supported APIs,
and then unsupported APIs.
And these are the ones that are
internal to the framework
that we don't guarantee
consistency on,
that can change over time.
And that problem is obviously
a difficulty for developers.
If you use one
of these, you know, frameworks
in your Dalvik code
and we change that API,
someday a user's gonna get,
you know, an over-the-air update
to their device, and, you know,
their favorite application--
your application's just gonna
stop working,
because you're using
an unsupported API.
That's a big problem
for you guys.
It's a big problem for us.
And the problem actually gets to
be quite a bit worse,
you know,
if you use the native code,
because not only
can we change the API
for some of these libraries
that aren't public,
we can actually change
the binary structure
of them as well,
which can also break it,
even if the API is the same.
So in other words, don't use--
you know, don't fall
to the temptation of using
other Native APIs in there,
unless you're willing to accept
the extremely huge risks
that go along with that
of having your app break
on a future version.
Um, so what can't you do?
I just mentioned this earlier.
Currently, the only APIs
that we're guaranteeing,
or that we plan
to guarantee stability for,
are libm,
which is the math library,
and libc,
which is the standard C library.
We do have plans
to add more over time,
but right now the focus
is on getting that early NDK
that I just mentioned.
We're trying to get that
polished up for release
hopefully in the next few weeks.
And so we'll add more over time,
but for the first version,
those are the only ones
we're planning to support.
The other thing you can't do
is hack the system.
This native code thing
that I'm gonna show you
does not represent, you know,
necessarily anything new.
There's no special privileges
to native code.
It's still subject to
the same sandboxing limitations
as, you know, all the other code
that runs on an Android device.
Um, so there's
no additional security risk,
or security burden,
imposed by using native code
in an application.
So now what I want to do
is show you guys a quick demo.
So I'm gonna come over here
and show you this directory.
So this is--
as I mentioned earlier,
this is an early build
of the Native Development Kit.
You can actually do this
yourself if you go to the--
check out the donut branch
from the public Git repository
and go through the work of
building your own cross-compiler
for whatever
your host platform is to ARM--
the appropriate ARM family
and so on.
So you can actually get this,
but I have kind of
a preliminary build here.
And the way
that this currently works
is there's two directories.
There's this apps directory
and this sources directory.
Under the apps directory,
HDICT's How Do I Code Thee,
is this one file
called application.mk...
which really just defines
an entry for my code
to be compiled and run.
And you can see here that I set
the destination directory
to be the directory where my
current Eclipse project lives.
And then this is the name
of the specific library
that I compile and then
some CFLAGS that I can set.
The other directory
is the sources directory.
And this is where
the actual C code lives.
And so here I have
this nativecluster.c file
and this android.mk file,
which really just tell it
how to build.
This has documentation, so I'm
not gonna go into the innards
of how this works.
But basically you just run
".mk APP="
and then the name of the app.
Um, actually,
I already built it recently,
so I have to...
And so then it runs a compile
and then drops
the resulting .so file
into my directory here.
So...
if I come back here and then
check out this libs directory,
you'll see that I now have
a directory with--
with the dynamically loadable
shared library
in this new directory
corresponding
to the current processor family.
So that's how I get
the actual native code.
Now, how do I actually use it?
And so for that,
I actually have...
another file in that directory,
which is this file here,
NativeClusterer.java.
And so if I--oops.
So if I drag this
and include this in my project,
now you see why I created
this Clusterer interface.
Over here in the K-Means view,
I'm basically just doing
a dependency injection here.
I have an interface clusterer
that knows how to implement
a clustering algorithm
in some way, shape, or form.
And at first, I just use
the Dalvik version of it.
But now that I have
this new Native implementation,
I can change that over
to a Native Clusterer.
And if I look
at this actual file,
you'll see that, um--
incredibly simple.
All I do
is a Static Initializer,
load the specific library
that I want to load,
and then, you know,
have a method cluster
that in this case
is declared Native,
and that's handled
by the C code.
So let's check out that C code.
So here again, you can see
that I have, again,
that same cartesian distance
calculator.
I have a struct
instead of a class
for holding
the point XY coordinates
in the current
cluster assignment.
And then here, really,
it's just the same function
that you've seen before.
I have a block here,
which is the, you know,
variable initialization.
Then again the main loop.
And once again, this should look
pretty familiar.
You know, until I converge
for every point,
um, for every cluster,
compute the distance.
You know, if the current point
now belongs to a new group,
you know,
update the assignments.
The only thing that's new here
are really a few things
such as here where I cache
some JNI objects,
and this is just
for performance
so I'm not constantly doing
a look-up
in the middle of a tight loop.
And then in here, I basically--
this is like a Field(env)
reference
in, you know, JNI parlance.
And then, of course, I just have
to do this additional step
of making sure that I keep track
of, you know,
garbage collector references,
so I don't overload
the virtual machine.
Um, and then--
so down here I have, again,
the same centroid
recalculation block.
Now, there's one thing I want
to point out about this.
You guys are probably familiar
with the fact that,
in C, you typically don't have
the same kind
of rich class libraries
as you have in, say,
Java or JavaScript.
So in the original version of
the Dalvik and Ajax versions,
I actually had a bunch of,
you know, like, HashMaps
and object-associative arrays
that I was using.
And, you know, well,
these things are fast, right?
They've been out
for a long time,
and they're well optimized.
In fact, they are, but in C,
I didn't have access
to anything like that,
so what I did was
I just kind of refactored
the algorithm
to, um, basically be
a flat array-based structure,
instead of having
to use HashMaps.
I also flattened an inner loop.
When I did that,
you know, I said,
"Okay, I got it working in C."
I'm like, "Well, it's not gonna
make any difference really,
"but I'm gonna go back
and refactor JavaScript
"and Java to use the same model
so they had
an apples-to-apples comparison."
Five times faster in both
JavaSource running in Dalvik
and JavaScript.
So I was kind of surprised
by that,
but really, what it means,
again, is just another example.
You know, these things--I'm not
gonna belabor this point,
'cause you can go
to Jeff Sharkey's talk,
I think, later today
on, you know, battery life
and performance,
but these things
are just not fast,
and, you know,
a little change like that
probably wouldn't matter much
on a desktop,
but it matters a huge amount
on a mobile.
So, um, when I did that,
you know, the C version
that you see here
kind of became the canonical
version of my algorithm.
Aside from that, it uses
the exact same rendering--
kind of pipeline
and rendering structure
as the pure Dalvik version.
So let me run this again.
So it's installing it
in the background.
Fires it up.
And you can see there
that it's running a lot faster.
Um, in fact, you can see
that, you know, the rendering
is taking
about the same amount of time,
but now I'm down to, like,
200 milliseconds.
I think I've actually got
something else going on
on my device at the moment,
'cause it usually runs
at about 150 milliseconds for--
you know, for the actual
calculation cycle.
So obviously,
quite a bit faster, as expected.
Okay, so...
switching back
to the slides again.
So, you know,
what are some examples
of what you can do with this?
Well, one
of my personal favorites
is this thing called SCUMMVM,
which is using--
which is an implementation
of a LucasArts game engine so
that you can play classic games,
and before you ask, yes,
I actually do have a license
to Zak McKracken.
One of my most cherished
software licenses, in fact.
Some of our partners, Spotify,
are also using this technique
to do some of their, um, uh...
low-level music-related
encryption calculations.
Unfortunately, I forgot to get
a screen shot of them.
So sorry about that.
So what's up for the future
of this technique?
Well, as I mentioned earlier,
you know, we're interested
in adding additional libraries,
but, you know,
right now we're focused
on, you know, polishing this
thing up
and then trying to get this
out there for you guys
as a, you know, standard tool
that you can use
as a complement to the STK.
So we haven't really,
you know, established
what's gonna come
in the future,
but one thing
I do want to stress
is we have no plans
to make this
sort of a separate
application stack.
The model that you just saw,
where Dalvik starts
and handles most
of the event logic and so on
and calls out to C code,
that's the model
that we're gonna be
focusing on.
And what I mean by a separate
event stack is things like,
you know, are you gonna be able
to write an application
that's entirely in C
and never starts
a Dalvik virtual machine?
The answer to that is no.
We think that, over time,
you know,
the optimizations
that we're making
to the core Dalvik libraries
will make it
even more compelling
than it is today
and that this will make
for a nice balance between
those two programming models.
Um, so now I want to do
a bonus demo.
I promised you a demo
of something earlier.
So let me come back here
to Eclipse.
In fact, to Finder as well.
So I have this site
that I showed you earlier,
and I have another file here
called index2.html.
So if I load this it does--
wait, this did nothing.
Why did this do nothing?
Um, well, it did nothing
because this is the source
for the page.
You get down to this point,
this line here,
and it crashed,
because what is this cluster
object in all capitals?
I don't know what that is.
So let me show you, you know,
what's going on here.
So I have this new file here
called KMeansWebViewActivity,
so I'm gonna drop this
into my project.
The other thing
I'm going to do is...
add this new layout
to my project called Alternate.
And so you'll see that, you
know, the WebViewActivity
actually relies on that
alternate layout file
to do its drawing,
so let me show you this code.
If anybody can tell me how
to get rid of these properties
and outline tabs permanently,
I would be forever in your debt.
Um, but so here is
the new activity I just added.
Again, this is a new screen
in the application.
It's gonna do
some different kind of work.
Um, and so here I have
this mysterious object class
called ClusterProxy--
ClustererProxy.
And it has a method
called Cluster,
and I'll come back to that.
So this is where, again, the--
you know,
the initialization occurs.
I set the--I specified
that this new alternate view
is gonna be my current view.
Um, and let's look
at that real quick.
In contrast to the first one
of these I showed you,
which was entirely
a custom view,
like, the entire screen
was occupied by a custom view.
In this case,
the entire screen is occupied
by one of these Web views
that's included with Android.
So then what I do is I grab
a handle to that Web view,
and then
I enable JavaScript on it,
and then I do this interesting
little line here.
And this is that method
I alluded to earlier,
addJavaScriptInterface.
What this is doing
is it's injecting
an instance
of this ClustererProxy
into the JavaScript namespace
under the name Cluster.
So what that means is,
if I go back to this thing,
when you run this
on an Android--
when you run this app
on an Android device,
it's actually injected
a Java object
with, you know,
appropriate shim stuff going on
into the JavaScript namespace
for JavaScript code
to actually make calls on.
Um, in this case,
all it's doing
is implementing the Clusterer--
the K-Means clustering
algorithm.
So I scroll up here...
and look at this mysterious
clusterer object.
You can see that all I do
is I do some data formatting
to get the data from JavaScript
in a form that I can use it.
I run the DalvikClusterer
on it,
and then I kind of do
some formatting of the results
and throw that back up
to JavaScript.
So let me run this for you.
Oh, and of course I forgot to--
I need to add it
to the Android manifest first.
Run this on my device.
Switch back to the...
So starting it up,
and this is gonna look
a lot like the Web version,
like the pure Ajax version...
except that what
it's actually doing again,
'cause I'm trapped
on the edge, it looks like,
it's actually downloading
the thing,
and this time it actually worked
on the Android browser.
Um...
so actually, you can't really
read the text at the bottom,
and it's backwards anyway.
But to relaunch this,
all I have to do is just quit...
and rerun it.
And there it is again.
Um...
I wish I could get it
to focus on the numbers.
Okay.
So in other words,
what I just did was I injected,
you know,
the Dalvik Clusterer version
of the clustering algorithm
into the code,
but I warn you,
what I'm about to do
I believe this to be banned
in 49 of the U.S. states,
and most Western religions
will excommunicate you
if you do this.
What I'm actually going to do
is switch this over
and use the Native Clusterer
and then rerun this application.
So in other words,
what this is actually doing
is this is starting
in JavaScript.
That's where the code
is running.
And instead of executing
the cluster algorithm
in JavaScript,
it's calling to Dalvik,
which is calling to--
through JNI down to C code.
So I'm actually, you know,
running this code.
Well, you can't see that 'cause
I didn't switch to the view.
I'm actually running this
using the Native version.
So you can actually see
the text there this time,
and it's at 589 milliseconds.
It actually was at approximately
1 second or 1.2 seconds
in the previous version.
So in other words, what I did
was I basically just took
the Native version of the code
and accessed that
from JavaScript.
So if you think
about that, though,
there's more to this
than just native code.
Um, that class--
that ClustererProxy object
can do anything.
It can talk to location API.
It can fire Intense
in the system.
Really what this represents
is a way
to augment your Ajax application
so that you can get access
to the rest of the system.
And this is--that's why we call
this technique,
or I call this technique,
Augmented Ajax.
So now I just kind of want
to wrap up
and say how do you actually
choose what you want to do?
So here's a table.
First, I want to focus
on the middle column.
First, look at the Dalvik
and the Native versions.
They have the same rendering
time, which you would expect,
since it's the same
rendering pipeline.
Um, JavaScript, though--
and these results, by the way,
are the average of ten trials
for each of these numbers
when there was nothing else
running on the device.
So the JavaScript version, which
is to say the Canvas version,
runs at 303 milliseconds.
Now, that's not slow by any
stretch of the imagination.
Obviously, it's much slower
than a desktop equivalent,
and it's quite a bit slower
than the "native code" rendering
pipeline available to Dalvik,
but for most human user
interactions, that's just fine.
And also drawing 500, you know,
1x1 rectangles
to a canvas
is not a common operation.
So, you know, what this means
is that, you know,
your takeaway here
should not be that you...
that canvas is slow,
but really, just that--
understand
what your application needs.
You know, perhaps another way
to look at this data
is in the third column
where I say the percent
of rendering time.
The rendering time takes
about 1/3 of the execution time
of the JavaScript version,
but it takes,
you know, depending on whether
you're running, you know,
with or without Native
assistance between 2% and 12%
of the total execution time
of the other models.
But again this doesn't mean
that it's slow
in any absolute sense.
It just means,
understand your application.
If you're doing
a lot of computation,
you know, maybe you want
to look into native code.
If you're, you know, just doing
a lot of UI updates,
you know, maybe you can go ahead
and use the JavaScript version.
Um, so I told you earlier
that I wasn't going to,
you know, give you a formula
or anything,
but instead I'll give you
this flowchart.
So if you're deciding
how to build an application,
you know, for an Android,
first you ask yourself,
do you have an existing Web site
that you want to integrate with?
If the answer is yes,
well, then the next question is,
is that an Ajax site?
Meaning that, are you--
do you already have, like,
a dynamic user interface?
If the answer is yes,
then you've probably
already implemented it
as something
like a REST Service.
If you haven't--
wait, if you haven't,
why are you in this room?
Like, why is your site
not Ajaxy right now?
Go to one of the other sessions
later today
and learn how to build
a really cool, you know,
Ajax-enabled site.
Um, and so you're gonna come
back to a REST Service anyway.
If you don't have
an existing Web site,
and we've determined
that if you do,
it's gonna be a REST site.
You know, and if you need
a Web site,
then, you know, you should go
ahead and build it as a REST.
But, you know, at this point,
you know,
the next question is, like,
"Well, what does your app
actually do?"
Does your app need
to be really fast?
If it doesn't, you know,
in the sense--
and by really fast,
I mean, like,
does it do a lot of rendering,
or does it, you know, do a lot
of computation?
If it's just a plain old app,
Ajax may work fine for you.
If it does need to be fast,
I'm not sure I believe you yet,
but if you do say it needs
to be really fast,
then, okay, go ahead
and use native code.
If you don't--
if it doesn't really need to be
screamingly fast,
then, yeah,
that's what I thought.
Go ahead and use Dalvik.
So...
but wait,
no, if you do use Ajax,
then there's another
sort of ancillary question.
Do you want to have the ability
to interact, you know,
in fancy-pants ways
with notifications and so on?
In which case, if you do,
you might need to use Dalvik
or use
this Augmented Ajax technique
that I showed you earlier.
You know, but then there's kind
of an all-important question
of, you know, "Wait, well, what
languages do you even know?"
If you don't know JavaScript
and you don't want to learn it,
is Ajax even an option for you?
You know, so your options
are C/C++, Java, JavaScript,
and, you know, these will go
back to one of the other models.
It's like, you know, haven't
we seen this somewhere before?
You know, and really the point
here--I'm making a joke,
but in the end, what this
basically boils down to is go
with what you know.
There's more
than one way to go.
than one way to do this.
You know, we're not trying
to tell you
that there's, you know,
one correct way
to build applications.
The way that we want you to
think of this is that, you know,
the centroid, in a way, of your
application can be anywhere.
It can be primarily Dalvik.
It can be primarily Ajax.
It can, you know, have
a large component
in native code.
And you can pull in components
from any, you know, methodology
or any aspect of the environment
that you want.
You know, Dalvik apps
can embed Web views.
Web apps can call into Dalvik.
You know, apps can include
native pieces.
Really, what it boils down to is
understand your application.
You know, there's nothing wrong
with wanting to use Dalvik
just because you know Java.
There's nothing wrong with
wanting to reuse your Ajax site
because you know JavaScript
really well,
and you're a JavaScript ninja.
And so again, just understand
the characteristics of your app,
know what you want to build,
and go with what you know.
So that's it.
That's all the material
that I have for you today.
And I'm happy to take
any questions.
There are two microphones here.
I guess we've only got
just a few minutes left,
so thanks for your time,
and I appreciate you coming.
[applause]
So if you have a question,
please head up
to one of the microphones
so that everybody can hear--
they're recording the session.
man:
Um, just real quick,
what's the cost
of the JNI piece?
So when you're calling out...
Morrill:
That's a great question,
and I actually
didn't measure that.
So I didn't measure, like,
you know,
the time before the call
and the time in the call
and the time returning.
Um, actually, if you want to
check out the source code there,
that URL, it would actually be
very easy to modify my code
to get those numbers,
but I didn't specifically
run that test.
man: Hey, Dan,
what's the memory limitation
for the processes?
Is it still 16 megabytes
if you invoke the native code,
or you can exceed that?
Morrill: That's
a good question, actually.
I'm not entirely sure
what the answer to that is.
16? Okay, yeah, it's enforced
at 16 megabytes per process,
my colleague says.
man: And the Java system
available memory
will report that memory
over native code or...?
Morrill: So Dalvik
will report the memory
that is known to Dalvik.
But you can use the standard,
you know, Linux tools
to see what the total
process memory usage is.
man: Thank you.
Morrill:
Question over here?
man:
I have a question for you.
[clears throat]
Before, what you were doing
was--you were doing
all the computation
in native code,
but then you were actually
drawing back in Dalvik.
Do you have any plans
to extend this
so that we can actually
just blip from native code
or draw natively?
Morrill:
An excellent question.
You know, we're certainly aware
that that's something
that people
want to be able to do.
But, you know, as I said
earlier, for now we're focused
on getting this thing launched
with, you know, some basic,
you know, tools and so on,
and, you know, we'll work
on adding additional APIs like
the ability to draw and so on
in a future version perhaps.
But if you want it here,
please, by all means,
join our developer forum
and let us know.
man: All right, thanks.
Morrill: Question here?
man: You mentioned
that NDK will be available
in donut branch,
but it's also there in cupcake.
I believe we support it
in cupcake.
Morrill: That's correct.
In fact, um...
what this basically boils down
to is this one method
called System.loadLibrary.
System.loadLibrary existed
in Android 1.0.
You can already do this.
The only thing that's new
is the ability
to have a toolchain...
There's two things
that are new:
the toolchain that is prebuilt
and compiles
your C code down to native code
and the guarantee
of a--of a couple libraries,
in this case libm and libc,
that are guaranteed
to be present
in a particular format.
So those are the guarantees
that you didn't have before.
From a technology perspective
you can already do this.
From a practical, you know,
should-you-do-this perspective,
until now,
you haven't been able to do it.
But, yes, we are hoping to be
able to release this NDK
for Android 1.5, even though
it's in the donut branch.
man: Thank you.
man: What is the extent
of support
that you're planning to provide
in native code?
So tomorrow will I be able
to create an activity
from the native code?
Morrill:
No, we don't plan to--
the core of the application
stack will still be driven
from Dalvik, so, like,
you know, that will handle
all the event processing
application lifecycles,
startup, teardown, and so on.
Native code will remain
just a chunk of code
that you can make calls into
through JNI.
man: Yeah, I agree with that,
but suppose I start
with the Dalvik,
the initial activity's created
by the Dalvik, but later on,
if I want to create
multiple activities
from the native code
for the same application...
Morrill: Oh, so are you asking
if you have,
like, a thread
and you call--and you want--
like, a thread running a native
code and you want to call
into a Dalvik class,
is that what you're asking?
man: Uh, yeah.
Morrill:
Uh, I actually don't think
we've thought
that far ahead yet.
Another thing that it would be
great to hear your feedback
about used cases and so on
in our developer forum.
man: Okay.
Thank you.
Morrill:
I think I'm out of time,
so I want to wrap up again.
And I'll be around.
So be around all day
today and tomorrow,
so I look forward to speaking
with many of you.
Thanks.
[applause]